je me suis concentré sur les violences
faites aux femmes dans le monde du
travail
de façon historique les femmes
aujourd'hui vont avoir des textes qui
s'appliquent la lutte contre les écarts
de salaires entre les femmes et les
autres ça s'appelle la directive
transparente des salaires il faut savoir
quand même qu'encore en moyenne on a 13
% des cartes salaires à travailler égal
entre les femmes et des hommes dans
toute l'Union européenne c'est
évidemment différent d'un pays à l'autre
ce texte il a été adopté jusqu'au bout
il va être transposé et il va obliger
les entreprises
donc à avoir plus de transparence quand
il y a des écartes salaires plus de 100%
elles vont devoir mettre en place un
plan d'action correctif et en tout cas
publier tous les ans ou tous les trois
ans selon leur effectif des informations
sur les écarts de salaires et s'il y en
a il y aura même un risque de sanction
donc c'est quand même à un texte majeur
qui va aussi obliger à informer tout
candidat toute candidate tout salarié
sur les salaires comment on a établi mon
salaire à l'embauche comment il se
positionne par rapport au salaire des
hommes dans la même pour le même travail
[Musique]
un second texte et majeur pour les
droits des femmes en Europe c'est une un
texte directive pour lutter contre les
violences faites aux femmes une femme
sur sur 7 fait l'objet de violence
conjugales de son conjoint ou
ex-conjoint avec des féminicides
malheureusement nombreux et donc l'idée
de ce texte c'est vraiment de trouver
des mesures adaptées de prévention aussi
lutter contre la
cybercriminalité qui est un fléau qui
est en pleine croissance par et qui
touche particulièrement les femmes et
moi je me suis concentrée sur les
violences faites aux femmes dans le
monde du travail et je défends l'idée
d'un aménagement du temps de travail
pour ses victimes et aussi un second
point important une formation pour les
employeurs
[Musique]